shout out I'll just say that to Jon
Stewart for standing up for the 911
First Responders who are not getting the
oh he did that a lot right and and it's
brilliant because the men who rushed
when when people were running away
rightly so there were people who ran
towards knowing what they had to do
knowing that they could leave their
children behind to have no father no
mother no family but they had to save as
many people as they could
and Joe Biden wasn't even commemorating
9 11. it's unfair to say that he did
what was he doing where he stopped in
Alaska is a typical refueling port for
Air Force One
what really happened in my opinion he
was traveling back from Southeast Asia
and stopped to refuel and they were like
well you might as well say something and
I was like oh okay yeah sure yeah Kamala
Harris went to New York instead that's
an embarrassment she's an embarrassment
yeah she's a horror she should have
absolutely no place near the White House
ever under any circumstance and she
typically doesn't I mean the Joe Biden
Administration does not engage with
Kamala that much